Caption: this morning we have an amazing keynote
Caption: speaker Christina Olden who is going to
Caption: be joining me on stage uh I might
Caption: introduce her while she gets her
Caption: computer set up
Caption: Christina has traveled all the way from
Caption: Las Vegas where I have found out people
Caption: live there
Caption: as well as just go to visit Christina
Caption: speaks at conferences all over the world
Caption: on various topics in Tech as well as
Caption: tedx has done a tedx talk which is great
Caption: because we have our own tedx sign on
Caption: stage here today so I hope Christina
Caption: will feel at home Christina is going to
Caption: be talking to us this morning about
Caption: memory which is great so we hope that
Caption: means that you will remember
Caption: Christina's talk as well as everybody
Caption: else's talk today so I'm going to hand
Caption: over to Christina to open the conference
Caption: this morning and thank you very much for
Caption: joining us Christina thank you
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: let's open this and keep this down here
Caption: certainly spill it otherwise
Caption: oh my life in the passcode okay
Caption: okay fantastic
Caption: [Laughter]
Caption: um
Caption: let's move this over here
Caption: right here
Caption: all right
Caption: brilliant
Caption: foreign
Caption: look at all you you're gorgeous
Caption: fantastic
Caption: foreign
Caption: I think a lot of us can relate to this
Caption: like you're having a dream right
Caption: and I mean you are in it like you are in
Caption: it deep and you are about to give
Caption: somebody like this person you cannot
Caption: even believe that they just said this to
Caption: you and you are having this dream and
Caption: you are really getting riled up right
Caption: you are really feeling it maybe your
Caption: heart is racing and they have really
Caption: ticked you off this last time and that's
Caption: it you are not going to deal with this
Caption: anymore you will not put up with maybe
Caption: you got a finger going right maybe maybe
Caption: you got a hand on your hip and your big
Caption: climax is supposed yes here you go and
Caption: suddenly
Caption: beep beep beep beep all right
Caption: your alarm
Caption: and you wake up and then maybe your
Caption: person is maybe they're there maybe
Caption: all right oh good morning oh oh don't
Caption: you good morning mate
Caption: right
Caption: it's not necessarily anything that that
Caption: they've done right but you still have
Caption: that experience your nervous system has
Caption: felt it you have the memory you see it
Caption: in your eye in your mind's eye right or
Caption: who's had this happen before
Caption: you're sitting around with your family
Caption: and you're telling a story
Caption: I do this four kids in my family so you
Caption: know we got lots of stories we get
Caption: together we start telling the story and
Caption: you're talking about how oh you know
Caption: remember that one time when mom sent me
Caption: down to the corner store and I had the
Caption: money in my hand and I was riding my
Caption: bike and I was going and then I fell off
Caption: the curb and like the coins went
Caption: everywhere and your brother goes hold on
Caption: that was me
Caption: I was the one who was with the money mom
Caption: sent me to the corner store I have the
Caption: scar on my knee to prove it like that's
Caption: that wasn't even you
Caption: right who's done that before
Caption: sometimes
Caption: we lock into these memories right we can
Caption: feel these stories we can drive this
Caption: narrative that's never even really
Caption: happened to us but we have this
Caption: experience
Caption: and so oftentimes our memories they'll
Caption: they'll drive a narrative to which we
Caption: become emotionally attached and
Caption: sometimes these emotional attachments
Caption: they can hold us back
Caption: and when stressed we lock into the way
Caption: that we feel
Caption: starts to become supportive of that
Caption: stress more and more and more and the
Caption: more we reinforce that feeling the
Caption: deeper those memories they get locked
Caption: into our neural Pathways and we'll talk
Caption: a little bit more about that process
Caption: later but you know with lots of help
Caption: from highly trained professionals
Caption: I've been able to learn how to navigate
Caption: stressful triggers by processing my
Caption: memories better and releasing emotional
Caption: attachments that are holding me back
Caption: I've learned to change the narrative
Caption: and
Caption: I've learned to understand when my
Caption: memory is reliable when my memory is not
Caption: reliable and how it serves me regardless
Caption: of the accuracy so today I want to share
Caption: some of that stuff that I've learned
Caption: about improving brain performance and as
Caption: always please just take what applies to
Caption: you and throw the rest away I'm not a
Caption: doctor I'm not a neuroscientist I'm not
Caption: a therapist but I do have first hand
Caption: experience overcoming trauma and I'm not
Caption: going to be talking about any of that
Caption: today but I've come to realize that the
Caption: stories that I've tell myself and others
Caption: they can either be the chains that bind
Caption: me or they can be the keys that Release
Caption: Me From that trauma that I aim to
Caption: overcome
Caption: my name is Christina Aldon I am a brand
Caption: strategy consultant I'm based out of Las
Caption: Vegas I'm a speaker trainer Mentor I'm a
Caption: certified mental health first aid for
Caption: Youth and for adults and I am really
Caption: excited to be here I sit in the board of
Caption: directors for a non-profit for stem and
Caption: also for mental health awareness if you
Caption: want to continue this conversation
Caption: please use the hashtag lucky memory
Caption: I want to say thanks so much to our
Caption: sponsors and to DDD Perth I personally
Caption: grew up in a teeny tiny little town in
Caption: the Midwest and in Michigan and I never
Caption: ever thought that I'd be able to travel
Caption: to Australia in fact I dreamed about
Caption: traveling to Australia when I was a kid
Caption: because it is the farthest way directly
Caption: on the other side of the planet from
Caption: where I grew up and so this is amazing
Caption: to me to be delivering the opening
Caption: keynote at DDD Perth and I just want to
Caption: say thanks so much to all of the
Caption: organizers and volunteers and the
Caption: sponsors for bringing us together today
Caption: so
Caption: so what
Caption: our memories they hold the key to better
Caption: communication to emotional intelligence
Caption: to being more open to the viewpoints of
Caption: others and for setting healthy
Caption: boundaries I just realized I'm doing a
Caption: lot of poses I'm going to stand here for
Caption: the rest of my talk because
Caption: nobody's winning bingo today
Caption: but you could see how as a brand
Caption: strategy consultant
Caption: um you know I'm always looking for ways
Caption: to connect products and services in
Caption: meaningful ways to our end users and and
Caption: to our customers you can see how this
Caption: stuff would be important to me when I'm
Caption: creating marketing funnels that have
Caption: emotional triggers attached to them so
Caption: what is memory
Caption: it's a faculty by which the mine stores
Caption: and remembers information something
Caption: remembered from the past it is a
Caption: recollection which is really a way to
Caption: say you know memory is the process that
Caption: we use to encode store and retrieve data
Caption: this affects our cognition that's how we
Caption: think about things and also it affects
Caption: our Behavior how we respond our
Caption: observable responses and so our brains
Caption: are constantly taking in data both
Caption: internal and external we have all of
Caption: these stimuli and we're processing data
Caption: in real time
Caption: based on all the new information that we
Caption: take in mixed with the information
Caption: that's already in there right and so
Caption: these days what we know as memory is
Caption: actually it's an interconnected group of
Caption: memory subsystems right we used to think
Caption: that there's left brain and right brain
Caption: that's actually not how our brains work
Caption: and these multiple memory systems
Caption: they're constantly processing data and
Caption: they're able to function together or
Caption: independently of each other
Caption: so memories are weird
Caption: memories can be compressed
Caption: our brain has this quality where you
Caption: know if the stimulus is the same over
Caption: and over again our memories will just
Caption: compress it because it's the same day
Caption: who's done this recently when you said I
Caption: do this oh yeah last time you were over
Caption: my house for dinner six months ago and
Caption: we did board games and we did
Caption: no Christina that was a year and six
Caption: months ago
Caption: because everybody's living been living
Caption: the same day over and over and over and
Caption: over again because of covid and so our
Caption: brain has this quality for efficiency
Caption: that it just compresses the memories
Caption: right and so remember it's our emotions
Caption: that that drive that narrative for our
Caption: memories and so even though we can't
Caption: give our brain more processing power
Caption: like like we can for our machines we can
Caption: just insert some more processing power
Caption: into our computers we can't do that for
Caption: our brains but we can
Caption: we can look for unconscious biases we
Caption: can look for inefficient processes in
Caption: our brains and we can actually with
Caption: practice
Caption: improve our brain performance so I'm
Caption: going to uh share with you some of the
Caption: ways that our brains might fail us and
Caption: ways that we can improve our memories
Caption: today and I'm not saying that you know
Caption: you can completely forget things or
Caption: that'll Erase Away things but we can
Caption: improve how we process things this has
Caption: especially been helpful for my mentees
Caption: for my coaching clients who are going
Caption: through long covid right who's been
Caption: experiencing a lot of brain fog in the
Caption: past couple of years that is a real
Caption: issue and so if you can just focus on
Caption: one of these techniques for three months
Caption: and then move on to the next one then
Caption: okay cool I'm going to share with you a
Caption: whole lot of techniques that I've
Caption: learned and been practicing in the last
Caption: four years it's been really cool
Caption: check this out
Caption: So today we're going to talk about these
Caption: types of memory systems we're going to
Caption: talk about the biological storage about
Caption: improving daily performance about your
Caption: confidence so for an example if you are
Caption: if you are if you're starting for a new
Caption: job right if you're starting a new job
Caption: and you get to introduce yourself to
Caption: people around the office you want people
Caption: to observe you
Caption: recognizing other people's names and
Caption: having that memory and holding on to
Caption: other people's names because then you
Caption: appear more confident and so that is a
Caption: quality that's going to be more
Caption: beneficial to you right
Caption: emotional intelligence we're going to
Caption: talk about that a little bit I could
Caption: talk about that all day but we don't
Caption: have all day and then you know conflict
Caption: conflict is inevitable and so there is a
Caption: one-way a extreme way to respond to a
Caption: situation and there's another extreme
Caption: way to respond to a situation I kind of
Caption: try to waver around the middle so that
Caption: when we have informed choices to choose
Caption: from then we're going to pick the best
Caption: possible response to get the best
Caption: possible results in a situation
Caption: so by Rick and ebbinghaus they're the
Caption: ones who conducted This research in 1984
Caption: and they found that most of the
Caption: forgetting happens between the ages of
Caption: four to five that's when our memory
Caption: subsystems start to develop and we have
Caption: two of them declarative and
Caption: non-declarative so we have a different
Caption: memory subsystem for for memorializing
Caption: like algebraic formulas for example or
Caption: or a different memory subsystem for
Caption: doing on the spot math right in fact
Caption: there's this quality called memory
Caption: consolidation who's heard of that before
Caption: memory consolidation it's when you go to
Caption: sleep right and you get the benefit of
Caption: consolidating your memories and and it
Caption: really strengthens those neural Pathways
Caption: and synaptic connections between the
Caption: neurons structurally and chemically that
Caption: is called memory consolidation
Caption: our declarative memory
Caption: it's your conscious memory
Caption: it involves effort involves intention
Caption: and so we can use intentional techniques
Caption: we do tests we do aptitude tests we do
Caption: the LSAT for attorneys we we do certain
Caption: um
Caption: mnemonics or repetition right and
Caption: biologically it's the hippocampus that
Caption: and the frontal lobes that manage this
Caption: part of our memory the declarative
Caption: memory system it can be measured with
Caption: those explicit tests so check this out
Caption: these are the three different types that
Caption: we have we have working memory and
Caption: people who struggle with ADHD usually
Caption: this is the type of memory subsystem
Caption: that is challenged most for them because
Caption: you only have two to 18 seconds for the
Caption: old information to collide with the new
Caption: information and then you process it
Caption: right the the biological part of your
Caption: brain
Caption: uh vasopressin is the ability to to help
Caption: you take in that new information and
Caption: then we have episodic memory episodic
Caption: memory this is our long-term memory
Caption: system
Caption: um but it's about specific life events
Caption: right this is where we we store our our
Caption: wedding day memories that one time when
Caption: Christina all done gave an amazing
Caption: keynote at DDD Perth wow right these
Caption: episodic memories when you're riding
Caption: your bike and you're holding on to the
Caption: coins and then your bike falls and the
Caption: coins go everywhere
Caption: episodic memory subsystem is where that
Caption: is stored and then we have our semantic
Caption: memory subsystem and you know this is
Caption: general knowledge this is two plus two
Caption: is four right the capital of loss of
Caption: Nevada is Carson City the the factual
Caption: general knowledge if I have a red ball
Caption: in my hand and I decide to fulling it
Caption: all the way to the back of the room take
Caption: that speaker pose bingo I have the Red
Caption: Bull and maybe for your semantic memory
Caption: maybe you see it okay did she throw it
Caption: yes was the ball red General factual
Caption: information there's no narrative or
Caption: emotion attached to it what happens when
Caption: we start attaching a memory to it that's
Caption: a a narrative to it that's a little bit
Caption: different
Caption: oh my gosh did you see Christina Wing
Caption: that ball right past my head she almost
Caption: hit me what a jerk right that's a
Caption: totally different memory subsystem
Caption: semantic memory only works with the
Caption: general knowledge
Caption: then there's non-declarative memory this
Caption: is your unconscious memory it is
Caption: inherently there it's automatically
Caption: there your biases instantly are there
Caption: and it requires zero effort it's
Caption: unintentional right biologically this is
Caption: our cortical areas of our brain the
Caption: cerebellum the basal ganglia they're the
Caption: ones that govern the non-declarative
Caption: memory subsystem and so this is really
Caption: imperative for forming new memories
Caption: you'll see if people have amnesia and
Caption: they're they're struggling with that
Caption: usually they have maybe damage to their
Caption: cerebellum or something like that and so
Caption: people can can improve by even you know
Caption: focusing on activities that are going to
Caption: stimulate the basal ganglia the cortical
Caption: areas the cerebellum and now of course
Caption: there are three different memory
Caption: subsystems priming our memory we can
Caption: prime our memory by repetition there are
Caption: certain things like
Caption: um you can prime your memory with a
Caption: perfume right you're at you're at the
Caption: grocery and you go walk by little old
Caption: grandma comes by and oh she smells like
Caption: your little grandma because she's
Caption: wearing that same perfume we can prime
Caption: our memory with those kinds of things
Caption: and then we also have conditioning
Caption: conditioning is like Pavlov's dog
Caption: who's heard of Pablo's dog here most
Caption: everybody right he rang the bell he fed
Caption: the dog the dog would salivate ring the
Caption: bell feed the dog dog would salivate
Caption: pretty soon all he had to do is
Caption: ring the bell that's it and the dog
Caption: would salivate exactly and so we can
Caption: condition our brain patterns through
Caption: things like neuro-linguistic programming
Caption: or through hypnosis certain techniques
Caption: that will help improve your condition
Caption: brain and then we have our motor
Caption: procedural memory this is a physical
Caption: repetition over and over and over again
Caption: hitting a baseball hitting a golf ball
Caption: dribbling a basketball these are motor
Caption: procedural memory subsystem stimuli
Caption: so when these different subsystems are
Caption: stimulated right they start encoding
Caption: storing and retrieving data together and
Caption: sometimes not together sometimes a
Caption: memory subsystem will be isolated from
Caption: the other one and it won't be activated
Caption: so for example it's taking it let's say
Caption: you're taking a math final hmm
Caption: all right we've learned semantic memory
Caption: is going to store that formula right
Caption: General factual knowledge cool all right
Caption: but then you sit down to take your math
Caption: final and your brain goes uh
Caption: somehow your short-term memory there is
Caption: not giving you access either maybe you
Caption: have an amygdala hijack and you're just
Caption: like panicking and you're freaking out
Caption: because you're not a person who takes
Caption: tests really well maybe like I said
Caption: maybe you have uh ADHD right and so that
Caption: that new information is colliding with
Caption: the old information and it's just
Caption: they're hitting a wall and it's not
Caption: happening right and so maybe
Caption: um this this is you're having a panic
Caption: attack this is this is a real thing for
Caption: a lot of people right
Caption: um and then on top of that maybe you're
Caption: suffering from the effects of of long
Caption: covid or maybe you're more of an
Caption: auditory learner and processor when it
Caption: comes to math maybe you're more of a
Caption: visual learner and process
Caption: visual uh cues when it comes to math
Caption: maybe you're more of an associative
Caption: learner right maybe you got to have your
Caption: favorite conference hoodie when you do
Caption: your math test because guess what it's
Caption: my lucky hoodie and we see this with
Caption: sport hurts people right we see this all
Caption: the time everybody's got to have their
Caption: lucky hoodie they're not going to shave
Caption: my beard because it's lucky I'm not
Caption: going to cut my hair whatever that is
Caption: but they're more associative and so
Caption: that's how they perform best
Caption: right
Caption: there are a lot of different Pro
Caption: approaches and the goal is to get your
Caption: brain to organize it information in a
Caption: way that is Optimum for you and guess
Caption: what there are 7.9 billion different
Caption: ways to do that ladies and gentlemen so
Caption: it's amazing that anything gets done at
Caption: all in fact we were talking about that
Caption: last night
Caption: but here's the thing brains they lie
Caption: right brains Lies We heard in the
Caption: beginning of of my talk brains light and
Caption: the more rigid our beliefs are the more
Caption: distracted we are the more our brains
Caption: are going to lie and if you talk to
Caption: police at a scene they will say that
Caption: eyewitness accounts are not accurate
Caption: they can interview 20 different people
Caption: who are all right there and you're going
Caption: to get 20 different answers because
Caption: again there's 7.9 billion different ways
Caption: to process those data and that
Caption: information right so for example
Caption: our brains can create false memories if
Caption: you are a person who struggles with
Caption: connecting with others and I mean
Caption: I mean this is a real thing for a lot of
Caption: people they deeply want connection and
Caption: crave connection but are unable to for
Caption: whatever reason
Caption: find it maybe you're sitting at home and
Caption: you're thinking about that
Caption: maybe you start ruminating a little bit
Caption: maybe you start feeling a little bit
Caption: from a victim mindset
Caption: maybe you start recalling past memories
Caption: through that victim mindset you can
Caption: actually create
Caption: false memories from that
Caption: and that narrative starts to drive how
Caption: you operate that narrative starts to
Caption: really shift how you see the world and
Caption: create these false memories and you know
Caption: our brains are totally capable of this
Caption: in cases of extreme trauma even your
Caption: brain might dissociate from the memories
Caption: altogether
Caption: so here's a perfect example let's say
Caption: you went to go see the new Avengers
Caption: movie I guess it's the doctor strange
Caption: one is that the ones come on
Caption: um
Caption: you go to see the new adventures movie
Caption: and you're like hey this is such a great
Caption: movie I love it you go with your friend
Caption: Joy
Caption: and you're sitting there watching the
Caption: movie and you're eating your popcorn and
Caption: it's awesome and the movie's over and
Caption: two weeks later you're like hey walking
Caption: down the street hey Joy what's up
Caption: you should go see that new Avengers
Caption: movie I went to John with John to see it
Caption: a couple weeks ago and it was amazing we
Caption: had such a great time there were
Caption: explosions the whole multi-universe
Caption: thing I mean it was so awesome enjoy
Caption: sitting there going
Caption: you're kidding right
Caption: it was me
Caption: I was there I was there with you and
Caption: here's the thing it's not that you did
Caption: it on purpose right gosh I love joy I
Caption: love John like we're all friends no it's
Caption: just that your focus
Caption: was on the movie itself and so your
Caption: brain just kind of fills in the the
Caption: friend spot I've totally done this
Caption: before by the way it's it's it's not
Caption: awesome
Caption: um but the you can you could totally
Caption: create these these false memories your
Caption: brain is is perfectly capable about that
Caption: of that
Caption: interruptions I want to say a quick
Caption: thing about interruptions because we
Caption: have retroactive and proactive
Caption: interference and I use this as a tool so
Caption: interruptions I work from home I am a
Caption: consultant when my kids come running
Caption: into my office they go hey Mom can I run
Caption: today I go just a minute
Caption: I give them one of those right because
Caption: interruptions are the number one reason
Caption: that we forget and it's the same thing
Caption: when we work in big open offices it's
Caption: the same thing when somebody runs in now
Caption: there's nothing wrong with this what
Caption: this does is it gives you a pause to
Caption: finish up the email to finish up the
Caption: thing to finish up the text thread hold
Caption: on get in line you're number three let
Caption: me just wrap these up right
Caption: in fact if you communicate with people
Caption: it's they're going to actually
Caption: appreciate and respect your boundaries
Caption: and they're not going to start running
Caption: into your office as much so and you
Caption: could you could just you know just one
Caption: let me just finish this up real quick I
Caption: have a thought let me finish it up
Caption: because you know what if you don't
Caption: it's gone
Caption: the interruption has to be significant
Caption: enough in order for you to forget it
Caption: though so if it's really fast and my
Caption: kids are just coming in hey can I have a
Caption: glass of milk yes go ahead I can keep
Caption: going no problem I'm not going to drop
Caption: the balls that I'm juggling right
Caption: however if they come in and they go mom
Caption: mom mom
Caption: [Music]
Caption: what right
Caption: or who's had this uh hey can I ask you a
Caption: quick question real quick just just take
Caption: five minutes
Caption: nope
Caption: give them one of these right
Caption: just a moment let me finish this thought
Caption: let me finish this email it's going to
Caption: be a really powerful tool and then
Caption: you're not going to lose that because
Caption: interruptions are the number one reason
Caption: why we forget take the look here look at
Caption: this what you see is not always what you
Caption: get
Caption: what you see is not always what you get
Caption: remember what I said eyewitness accounts
Caption: are not accurate they are not dependable
Caption: and if you ask 20 different people that
Caption: have seen you're going to get 20
Caption: different answers this has been proved
Caption: over and over again replicated in
Caption: Laboratories and research all over the
Caption: planet that we cannot always trust our
Caption: memories because
Caption: brains lie so how can we improve our
Caption: memory it's totally possible we can
Caption: improve our memory we can improve our
Caption: capacity for Learning and we can improve
Caption: our ability to encode store and retrieve
Caption: data this is how we do it we used to
Caption: think that our brains were so much more
Caption: limited
Caption: eight nine ten years ago we didn't know
Caption: anything about the brain we used to say
Caption: you can't teach an old dog new tricks
Caption: who said that before
Caption: stop saying that
Caption: it's not true
Caption: in fact you can teach an old dog new
Caption: tricks in fact you can start creating
Caption: new neural Pathways as early as five to
Caption: six hours your brain will start rewiring
Caption: it's pretty cool if the stimulus is
Caption: strong enough or repetitive enough
Caption: we can rewire our brain I know this I am
Caption: a living proof of this as somebody who
Caption: has overcome trauma as somebody who at
Caption: one point was even catatonic for nine
Caption: days straight I did not speak
Caption: these are the ways that I have learned
Caption: to improve my brain performance and I
Caption: use it with my mentees my Consultants my
Caption: coaching clients everybody and it's
Caption: really really cool so this is
Caption: neuroplasticity in action right so if we
Caption: strengthen that neural pathway and we
Caption: stimulate it over and over and over
Caption: again then we start to learn things if
Caption: the stimulus is strong enough or
Caption: repetitive enough it will stick also
Caption: if we stop the stimulus
Caption: those neural Pathways will dissolve
Caption: right
Caption: so think about it it makes sense that
Caption: just reading a book about emotional
Caption: intelligence or memory it's it's not
Caption: going to instantly improve you have to
Caption: actually practice these things over and
Caption: over and over again or the stimulus has
Caption: to be strong enough ladies and gentlemen
Caption: imagine teeny tiny little Christina I
Caption: take you back you know 40 some years ago
Caption: crawling around the floor of my
Caption: grandmother's house and in the US we
Caption: have um we have won 10 volts but you
Caption: know what this this I I think you get
Caption: the picture we are uh looking at me
Caption: crawling around my grandmother's house
Caption: and I pick up one of those metal
Caption: hairpins
Caption: and it happens to be the perfect size
Caption: for just
Caption: crying and crying oh my gosh
Caption: it bit me it bit me right my mom had no
Caption: idea what bitter because we didn't have
Caption: dogs we didn't like what was it what bit
Caption: her I had no no it bit me and then she
Caption: realized that I'd stick the bobby pin
Caption: into the socket how many times do you
Caption: think I stimulated that neural pathway
Caption: in my life
Caption: once
Caption: once that was all that was needed for me
Caption: to learn the lesson if the stimulus is
Caption: strong enough or repetitive enough you
Caption: will remember it and also
Caption: neuroplasticity just as we will remember
Caption: it we can forget it so my French teacher
Caption: used to say if you don't use it
Caption: you lose it
Caption: that's why the only thing I can say in
Caption: French is
Caption: are you a tie
Caption: it's completely useless I don't know
Caption: three years of French it's unbelievable
Caption: and so we we went through the different
Caption: kinds of memory subsystems we we talked
Caption: about the the value of neuroplasticity
Caption: we talked about how
Caption: um memories can be false let's talk a
Caption: little bit about how we can process our
Caption: memories
Caption: we have shallow processing superficial
Caption: or deep where we have that purpose
Caption: attached to the data when we have
Caption: something that's meaningful to us now
Caption: remember there are 7.9 billion different
Caption: ways to do this and that means
Caption: introverts and extroverts are going to
Caption: respond to the same stimuli in a
Caption: different way if you are in teams we
Caption: need to understand this and we need to
Caption: take this into consideration uh
Caption: devnikima put up a really great Twitter
Caption: post that she said I could use as we
Caption: were putting as I was putting my talk
Caption: together front load the data
Caption: front load me with information give me
Caption: time to process and respond I'm not an
Caption: on-the-spot thinker but give me time to
Caption: be thoughtful and it's worth the wait
Caption: give me reference material make
Caption: asynchronous collaboration possible my
Caption: brain's not always lit up and ready for
Caption: output allow me to communicate in text
Caption: that's a big one for me that's a really
Caption: big one for me because is anybody else
Caption: really good like you go home and you're
Caption: like oh I should have totally said this
Caption: oh that's smart ass I should have gave
Caption: him that dig and I would have really
Caption: right
Caption: oh I had the perfect response four days
Caption: later like the other person's not even
Caption: thinking about the conversation anymore
Caption: you know
Caption: real-time meetings are allowed to
Caption: process at once and I'm already short on
Caption: working memory I'm probably bored and
Caption: it's taking everything I have just to
Caption: stay focused and listen for
Caption: understanding this is especially true
Caption: during covid times here is a summary of
Caption: what dev nakima has to say
Caption: understanding this it helps us support
Caption: everyone on the team so that everyone
Caption: can perform better on the job if you are
Caption: going to come right out of the gate hey
Caption: everybody all right let's go let's get
Caption: this meeting started right extroverts
Caption: are going to go yeah let's go this is
Caption: awesome
Caption: I got ideas we're gonna start talking
Caption: over each other oh I got some creative
Caption: things let's go and all of those
Caption: introverts are gonna go
Caption: yes it's going to be one of those
Caption: meetings again
Caption: I'm gonna check out
Caption: I'm gonna sit back
Caption: and quietly resent you
Caption: and they're gonna wait for the big
Caption: moment two months later when the poop
Caption: hits the fan and they're gonna say
Caption: I told you so
Caption: I told you two months ago
Caption: right because they respond to the same
Caption: exact stimuli in different ways and we
Caption: need to understand this and this is why
Caption: we have to have all types of
Caption: communication and and facilitation
Caption: during during our meeting so
Caption: let's talk about encoding memories ways
Caption: that we encode
Caption: our memories
Caption: our Focus right you could train your
Caption: brain to recognize patterns for example
Caption: you might want to think about trying to
Caption: recognize somebody in a happy cheerful
Caption: moment and then the next day two happy
Caption: cheerful moments and then the next day
Caption: three happy cheerful moments and then
Caption: the next day four happy cheerful moments
Caption: because you know what we are really good
Caption: at finding the not so good moments we
Caption: don't need that that's already implicit
Caption: in our brain looking and scanning for
Caption: threats so think about what your focus
Caption: is remember the popcorn eating while
Caption: watching the movie and eating popcorn
Caption: with your friend and then you're like oh
Caption: sorry Joy but what's your focus
Caption: next you can also train your brain with
Caption: a Slow and Low
Caption: let's try it right now ready Slow and
Caption: Low
Caption: so these small intentional changes
Caption: that's how big changes are made and when
Caption: we have a relaxed nervous system we are
Caption: going to be able to take in information
Caption: a whole lot better we can create our own
Caption: opportunities we can create our own luck
Caption: we can improve our encoding
Caption: through a technique
Caption: that's called the memory card technique
Caption: I'm from Las Vegas we love to play cards
Caption: in Vegas so you take some cards you lay
Caption: them all out and you can try to remember
Caption: them you can do things like try to
Caption: remember the order of the 52 deck of
Caption: cards you can do things like try to
Caption: remember all of the cards that have a
Caption: white background you can remember all of
Caption: the black cards all of the red cards and
Caption: after you do this over and over and over
Caption: again what you're doing is you're
Caption: training your brain to encode data
Caption: better and faster
Caption: you can also do this through action this
Caption: boosts our episodic memory encoding
Caption: because it releases noradrenaline and so
Caption: if you've got a wobbly kid like me right
Caption: when they're studying give them a wobble
Caption: cushion because they're going to wiggle
Caption: at school and so wiggle this is how we
Caption: get a lot of like um Active Learning
Caption: right and and different types of seats
Caption: in classrooms that the teachers these
Caption: days uh are always advocating for right
Caption: a more experiential Active Learning
Caption: environment is going to be a lot more
Caption: helpful for many Learners here's a new
Caption: one this is in you can improve your
Caption: coding by the shoot the thumb technique
Caption: who has heard of this one shoot the
Caption: thumb technique is awesome and I'm going
Caption: to really embarrass myself okay here we
Caption: go uh shoot the thumb technique you
Caption: gotta shoot your thumb here we go all
Caption: right I got it okay I'm gonna shoot my
Caption: thumb all right so you shoot your thumb
Caption: while you are holding on to a memory and
Caption: the cool part about this is is you get
Caption: bilateral stimulation of both
Caption: hemispheres of your brain and as this
Caption: information goes across your brain
Caption: bilateral across your hemispheres you
Caption: are oh look I'm talking in it okay
Caption: um you can
Caption: have other data transfer across those
Caption: neural Pathways it's not just that one
Caption: memory that's held and so it's a really
Caption: effective teaching strategy
Caption: um for for helping to improve encoding
Caption: um
Caption: let's see shoot the thumb transmitting
Caption: data yes oh spacing effect the spacing
Caption: effect is one that I use for my for my
Caption: pubconf talks any of my ignite talks
Caption: those five minute super fast talk I did
Caption: this with my tedx talk when I did that
Caption: one you can
Caption: um read your talk or your list
Caption: and then say it out loud when you're
Caption: saying it out loud you're feeling your
Caption: vocal cords you're hearing it yourself
Caption: do it you're feeling you're writing it
Caption: on the paper not just typing it out
Caption: right and then read your list again or
Caption: your talk again
Caption: go to sleep you get take advantage of
Caption: that that memory consolidation technique
Caption: that we talked about earlier right
Caption: remember and then when you wake up and
Caption: you repeat it the next day you're going
Caption: to significantly remember that
Caption: information this is a very very
Caption: effective technique
Caption: the other thing you can do is relax you
Caption: can improve your memory according but
Caption: encoding by relaxing again this allows a
Caption: neurotransmitter vasopressin to be
Caption: released and that makes us much more
Caption: open to receiving information right so
Caption: you can take a nice big breath and you
Caption: can relax so here is a summary of how we
Caption: can improve in coding if you just take
Caption: one of these techniques and practice it
Caption: every single day for three months I
Caption: promise you you will improve your memory
Caption: encoding
Caption: let's talk about storing our memories
Caption: we can use our senses sight sound smell
Caption: touch taste we have a sense of agency we
Caption: have a sense of blushing a sense of
Caption: hunger a sense of time the more that we
Caption: can incorporate those the more we're
Caption: going to remember it right so for
Caption: example think about you you have songs
Caption: that put you right back into that moment
Caption: right I think about uh uh the Rolling
Caption: Stones I think about I Can't Get No
Caption: Satisfaction it takes me right back to
Caption: that time like cruising in the car with
Caption: the windows down and the hair and I was
Caption: like so young right like we all have
Caption: certain songs
Caption: that means something to us because of
Caption: the way that we've stored those memories
Caption: here's the thing about senses
Caption: they can be tricked right you add a
Caption: shadow and suddenly it creates an
Caption: illusion so you can't depend just on one
Caption: of your senses
Caption: storytelling storytelling is another way
Caption: that we can really remember things are
Caption: as humans we love stories we love
Caption: stories I grew up in the midwest on the
Caption: shores of Lake Superior and my uncles
Caption: they used to tell the grandest stories
Caption: of that fish they caught
Caption: and every time they told the story The
Caption: the fish would get a little bit bigger
Caption: and a little bit bigger and a little bit
Caption: bigger and before you know I'd be like
Caption: hey remember that time when you caught
Caption: that big fish yeah and then everybody
Caption: knows the story and we've all heard it
Caption: so many times so storytelling is another
Caption: way to help with your memory storage our
Caption: hippocampus is the way is the place in
Caption: our brain that that stores it and of
Caption: course you know any of that bilateral
Caption: thinking
Caption: is going to help any of that bilateral
Caption: stuff because what we know is that our
Caption: brains store things in chunks we love
Caption: chunks this is why we do things like uh
Caption: we do phone numbers who's done this
Caption: before
Caption: okay yeah let's let's trade numbers cool
Caption: all right yeah all right you get your
Caption: paper out
Caption: you get your pen you're ready to go okay
Caption: go ahead I'm I'm ready all right it's
Caption: 172 to
Caption: 21 20 wait wait wait wait wait okay no
Caption: your phone number yeah that is my phone
Caption: number okay it's it's it's
Caption: one seven hundred and two two two two
Caption: two and then we're gonna do a 15 no just
Caption: give it to me like a human and not a
Caption: psychopath okay would that be all right
Caption: with you listen it's the Cadence it's
Caption: the tone we like to chunk data it's one
Caption: seven zero two two two two one five one
Caption: five everybody knows you like the chunks
Caption: right we like chunks of data and so that
Caption: is how you can improve your memory
Caption: storage some basic influencing factors
Caption: and so we could do things like uh
Caption: meditate
Caption: right I meditated this morning sat down
Caption: and did a little
Caption: um just before we got on because I like
Caption: to be nice and relaxed it's going to
Caption: help us improve our learning our our
Caption: capacity for empathy and our memory
Caption: after just eight weeks of meditating
Caption: even if you've never even meditated
Caption: before our brains will have more gray
Caption: matter and development in those areas
Caption: the other thing that we can do
Caption: is get in touch with our feelings
Caption: if we get in touch with our feelings and
Caption: our emotions we're going to remember
Caption: more remember emotions are what drive
Caption: that narrative and so that is going to
Caption: have a positive or it can have a
Caption: negative right effect on inhib
Caption: inhibiting or prohibiting those
Caption: neurotransmitters to Accurate activate
Caption: parts of our brain so taken to the
Caption: extreme if you're too emotional then you
Caption: might need to work a little bit on your
Caption: your psychological boundaries with
Caption: people right so get in touch with your
Caption: feelings
Caption: here's the other thing you can do is
Caption: Association for example putting on your
Caption: favorite hoodie or or or attaching that
Caption: new information to something that's
Caption: already in there I do a workshop about
Caption: this where we actually do practice
Caption: things and we build a Memory Palace and
Caption: I show you exactly how to associate
Caption: certain memories with certain things and
Caption: and that's already being retained
Caption: the other thing we can do is we can
Caption: create chaos and you can break habits
Caption: where you're not really actually
Caption: they're not actually serving you anymore
Caption: instead you know sometimes we just have
Caption: information in there and we just do it
Caption: just because so there's the the story of
Caption: the the Thanksgiving dinner or the
Caption: Christmas dinner and then the mom is
Caption: preparing it she's showing her daughter
Caption: how to how to make the ham and how to
Caption: cook it okay cool so she takes in she
Caption: puts all the seasonings on it and she
Caption: she sets it down and she whacks it in
Caption: half and she puts it in two pans and
Caption: then she puts it in the oven the
Caption: daughter goes that's great mom but why
Caption: do we whack it in half like what's she
Caption: said I don't know that's just the recipe
Caption: that's how our family does it that's
Caption: what grandma always said and she goes to
Caption: Grandma and she says hey
Caption: how can we cut the ham in half what's
Caption: what and she said oh well we just never
Caption: had a pan big enough so yes
Caption: so think about why you're doing things
Caption: don't just put things onto autopilot
Caption: over and over again we can improve our
Caption: storage through repetition remember if
Caption: the stimulus is strong enough or
Caption: repetitive enough right you can
Caption: strengthen those neural Pathways you get
Caption: more protein synthesis the myelinated
Caption: sheaths get bigger we get more bundles
Caption: more neural Pathways in fact
Caption: um through that memory subsystem and so
Caption: um it's estimated in marketing and
Caption: advertising in my world that somebody
Caption: needs to see something 21 times before
Caption: before it sticks into our skulls and so
Caption: you know we're exposed to that same
Caption: messaging over and over and over again
Caption: you could see how this would be positive
Caption: you could see also how this might be be
Caption: harmful as well
Caption: we can improve storage by better
Caption: documentation we see this in Tech right
Caption: we can make documentation about why
Caption: choices are made and also why not
Caption: choices were made because if we right
Caption: now say we're not this isn't going to
Caption: work for us if we write y two years down
Caption: the road funding might become available
Caption: right so maybe we can change that
Caption: decision and it's documented right there
Caption: instead of everybody going hmm now why
Caption: did we do this why didn't we do that I'm
Caption: not sure the project manager's gone
Caption: sales team's long gone and nobody really
Caption: understands why those those choices and
Caption: decisions were made we can also improve
Caption: our storage by facilitating our meetings
Caption: better remember somebody if if they
Caption: bring an idea to the table for example
Caption: and then two months later somebody
Caption: brings up that same idea and they go hey
Caption: let's do this
Caption: yeah I I think that was a great idea
Caption: that it was a great idea two months ago
Caption: when I brought it up
Caption: but your focus wasn't on the who because
Caption: instead you were focused on on the what
Caption: so we can improve storage by you know
Caption: having a better facilitated meetings
Caption: and the last thing for improving storage
Caption: I must mention is the Von restorf effect
Caption: this is
Caption: the things that are unique are going to
Caption: stand out and be remembered the most so
Caption: I worked in a hotel during my uh college
Caption: Years in the summer and there was a
Caption: police officer there with his dog
Caption: partner and they were they were training
Caption: and he was staying in the hotel and he
Caption: and another officer were sitting there
Caption: in the lobby one night and we were all
Caption: talking and they were making fun of me
Caption: because they're like oh yeah your white
Caption: car you you better stop speeding because
Caption: I I see white cars better right and the
Caption: other police officer who's like no I
Caption: actually see red cars better because
Caption: they stand out to me more and so he gave
Caption: more tickets to to cars that were red
Caption: cars as opposed to any other color of
Caption: cars and and that's the Rand van
Caption: restorff effect so we can take advantage
Caption: of things that maybe are a little bit
Caption: more unique and they're you're going to
Caption: uniquely stand out
Caption: here is a summary of that
Caption: and so the last one
Caption: I want to talk about how we retrieve our
Caption: memories and so
Caption: um something that influences uh that you
Caption: know is tolving he's the one who
Caption: he proposed that that forgetting
Caption: oftentimes is just a matter of memory
Caption: retrieval and so I think this was 1983
Caption: yeah so this is when like
Caption: um you have that actor's name on the tip
Caption: of your tongue and it's right there and
Caption: you know he's that guy with the head the
Caption: two worms he was in that show with the
Caption: with the person right that's that's what
Caption: the he's referring to when we start
Caption: talking about memory retrieval and so
Caption: another example I do this I walk into my
Caption: kitchen and I go
Caption: hmm now what the hell I come in here for
Caption: like what am I right and so what do we
Caption: do we backtrack we associate what we
Caption: were thinking and and how so we can
Caption: retrieve those memories give it a cue
Caption: give it a prompt and then we can move
Caption: forward so one way that we can improve
Caption: our memory retrieval is we can use the
Caption: same method
Caption: so different cues help us manage our
Caption: mindset and so uh we can improve our
Caption: memory retrieval by matching and
Caption: encoding uh the the matching the
Caption: encoding and the retrieval cues right
Caption: and if you use that same method every
Caption: single time like sometimes people will
Caption: say all right I use the same method for
Caption: creating a password
Caption: then it helps you remember the password
Caption: without even having to remember 4 000
Caption: passwords all the time and it also helps
Caption: you as you change those passwords right
Caption: you can also do intentional recall your
Caption: mood and other biases you know there
Caption: whatever is in that moment they're going
Caption: to influence the information that you
Caption: recall so if you want to improve your
Caption: memory retrieval
Caption: consider that mindset that you're that
Caption: you're in and then you know move forward
Caption: with intentional recall intentional
Caption: recall is then how we teach that
Caption: information to people right if we
Caption: feed it back to somebody this is what I
Caption: learned then we are going to be much
Caption: more able to retrieve memories in the
Caption: future we're training our brain to think
Caption: that way so consider maybe how the
Caption: information could be applied to your
Caption: work that you've learned in the
Caption: conference this uh this afternoon right
Caption: think about
Caption: um how maybe you are going to long-term
Caption: store something through Association
Caption: that's also going to help imprint it
Caption: into those neural pathways
Caption: the other thing you can do is stay
Caption: healthy surprisingly or not
Caption: unsurprisingly right sleep
Caption: eating safety discomfort stress these
Caption: things really affect your memory
Caption: retrieval and then the last one is to
Caption: observe mindlessness right memories they
Caption: can be malleable and so it's really
Caption: important to to bring your observation
Caption: skills to the table maybe you want to
Caption: take a different route to work or a
Caption: different route home and just observe
Caption: the things around you instead of
Caption: normally maybe you drive and you arrive
Caption: at your destination and you go hmm I
Caption: didn't really I guess I was kind of on
Caption: autopilot right you kind of dissociate
Caption: from the experience and so maybe it's
Caption: time to sharpen the edges of your foggy
Caption: mind in some of those places so take a
Caption: look here this is the ways that we can
Caption: improve our memory retrieval
Caption: the methodology
Caption: managing your mindset intentional
Caption: recalls staying healthy and observing
Caption: mindlessness so
Caption: those are the mem the ways you can
Caption: improve retrieval
Caption: as you go through the rest of the
Caption: conference
Caption: I want you to think about these
Caption: questions okay I want you to think about
Caption: what you are remembering from the talks
Caption: that you're seeing is there a pattern of
Caption: the things that you notice are you
Caption: sticking with certain topics are you
Caption: sticking with certain speakers
Caption: um why
Caption: compare your notes and Foci I want you
Caption: to talk to somebody else with
Caption: intentional recall ask them what were
Caption: they focusing on what were you focusing
Caption: on why and teach them oh this is what I
Caption: learned out of this talk from this
Caption: speaker what did you learn when we have
Caption: that it's going to help us remember the
Caption: content more
Caption: what surface processing did you use the
Caption: shallow processing what deep processing
Caption: maybe there were things that were more
Caption: meaningful and had more purpose to you
Caption: right what distractions occurred it'd be
Caption: wise to turn off your notifications
Caption: while you're in in speaker rooms and
Caption: trying to pay attention so you're not
Caption: having all these different distractions
Caption: pop up right
Caption: so memory can be a very tricky thing and
Caption: if nothing else today I would like you
Caption: to remember this here's it's the big
Caption: secret
Caption: everybody's so worried about finding out
Caption: and that's you know we all Google the
Caption: things
Caption: we all Google the things right and we
Caption: all forget and as we've learned today
Caption: memories can be faulty they can create
Caption: false memories we can uh get stuck and
Caption: not be able to retrieve the the data
Caption: that we already know and you don't have
Caption: to memorize all the things having the
Caption: ability to think think creatively
Caption: through a solution that's where our
Caption: strength lies and each of us puts our
Caption: own unique creative way of approaching
Caption: the solution to a client's problem and
Caption: you know it doesn't matter if we have to
Caption: use the Googles right to to look up how
Caption: to do things and having all of these
Caption: coding tests and and only one memory
Caption: subsystem to to test you know I just
Caption: really don't think that it's it's
Caption: effective and the same thing goes with
Caption: our kids teaching them to just blindly
Caption: follow things and memorize things
Caption: without a purpose it doesn't make sense
Caption: it stifles their creativity and they
Caption: lose the ability to make an informed
Caption: choices
Caption: so as I stand in front of you today
Caption: I encourage you all
Caption: job Seekers hiring managers parents and
Caption: I even want to appeal to the little
Caption: inner child inside of all of us how well
Caption: that we remember something is not what
Caption: defines our intellect it's how we apply
Caption: that information that's what matters
Caption: with empathy with healthy boundaries
Caption: with creativity and with collaboration
Caption: we all grow together
Caption: thank you
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: and one more thing I wanted to ask if
Caption: anybody remembers if I was wearing a
Caption: sweater at the beginning of my talk or
Caption: glasses
Caption: or a scarf
Caption: or a ponytail at all
Caption: it's it's important I think to kind of
Caption: remember what our focus is on and what
Caption: we are taking away from all of these
Caption: talks because every single person is
Caption: going to get something different out of
Caption: our talks today and it's going to be a
Caption: missed opportunity if you aren't able to
Caption: challenge each other and to share that
Caption: information together so thank you very
Caption: much
Caption: thank you